on a une autre qui a été énorme ici
ailleurs a franchement je vous jure j'en
ai pleuré de rire c'est kelly qui a
piégé une salle d'attenté d'un centre
médical et kelly est sujette à des
flatulences benjamin regarder ça c'est
très très fort c'est dans la grande
brasserie à 3 regarder
si tu vas les assumer
[Musique]
m
oh
ah la la
non
[Musique]
m
oh
oui ça va merci moment rapide
oui je sens que c'est vraiment froid
[Applaudissements]
ça fait un moment bâtiment à 4 à un peu
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est pas moi c'est pas moi madame
pitt alors c'est comme ça bah c'est bon
bah ouais ouais j'en veut tous avoir mal
aux côtes en baisse à bon nombre de
hobbies amazon c'est pas mal d'accord
c'est ma faute ça vous énerve aussi
madame somme énergie sa mère
oui je sais madame en cause mais madame
je ne suis pas agressif mais c'est
désagréable
désolé je suis très choquée votre
attitude et patients sont malades
oui ou s'ils peuvent d'accord avant le
médical quand vous avez écrit d'ailleurs
failli passer sa convalescence gastro
entérologue qu'il faut qu'elle voit
skoda
[Musique]
je sais pas si monsieur ça sans quoi un
pas ça sent pas la caméra cachée
[Musique]
mais tout est un peu gênant
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]